welcome back to Piers Morgan nonsense
and transgender cyclist Austin killitz
won the women's event this year's tour
of the Gila she's biologically male and
he took up cycling in 2019 before
beginning hormone replacement therapy
after kill his victory the tools
director Michael engelman's the very
future of women's sport is now on the
line he's since been subjected of course
to abuse and threats but he joins me now
to double down on what he said so Mike
Linderman thank you very much indeed for
joining me it's a predictable pattern
something ridiculous like this happens
which clearly erodes the Integrity of
women's sport and is in my opinion
grotesquely unfair somebody like you who
understands this Sport and the danger
this represents says so and you get
immediately shamed vilified bullied and
hounded because that's the way this
debate is suppressed first of all how
have you dealt with the backlash that
you've received
well I think on the whole it's in the
end it was kind of positive I mean I
think part of the it's a confusing
subject right
um
UCI has rules we follow those rules uh
the athletes follow those rules
um the rest of the world doesn't
understand that it looks very unfair and
in certain regards it is
so I I think we've been preparing for
this issue for a year now probably the
sport has I'm hoping that the ioc and
the UCI will step up
um and I think this kind of forces the
issue so to answer your question I mean
I think we just let it wash off our
backs I mean there is at the center of
this just a call principle which is is
it fair for biological males who then
become transgender there's nothing to do
in my estimation with supporting
transgender rights I support that
completely but when you see what's
happening in cycling in swimming in
athletics in almost every sport now as
the volume of transgender athletes
increases exponentially what you're
seeing are people who performed very
mediocreally at their own sex level so a
biological male uh when they compete
against biological males they don't do
as well when they compete as biological
males against women then they are
winning and that cannot be right
it's certainly not the view for those of
us in performance and obviously we're
looking at this from the the elite side
right so sometimes Elite Sports is like
realize sometimes it's not
um the UCI has set a series you know
they they supposedly looked at uh
research done by the Canadian Center for
ethics on Sports
um review that data and said that they
felt that transgender athletes that had
transitioned for two years were it was
fair for them to compete there's tons of
contradictions in that study I think
John Pike from the UK has spelled those
out pretty well among many others
um why the UCI is sticking to something
that
really does not look fair and it does
not appear to be fair we cannot
understand and I'm with you everybody's
for the rights of trans people this
that's not the issue here the issue here
and I would look at Austin as a
performance person and Austin was third
at tour The Gila last year
um you know we did my job as competition
directors to work with UCI the USC
cycling our governing body make sure we
stick within the rules we knew I was
sure Austin would win this year and um I
think the performance even though it's a
very difficult race was called mediocre
she raised as fast as she needed to do
to win
I would say at some levels from what
I've seen in her performance she may be
one of the best women's cyclists in the
U.S
um and it's a number of Olympic
medalists and world champions have won
Tour of the Gila and the issue here that
we have is the physiology of it
um you know if if an athlete transitions
are they the same as a woman well the
question I would have the question is
you just said one of the best female
athletes in the world well I don't know
how you phrase it because Austin's not a
female right it often's a biological
male he's transitioned uh to be a
transgender athlete fine but how would
Austin do against biological males and
Austin would not be one of the best
biological male cyclists in America very
very far from it that's where the clear
evidence is this why are things like the
Olympics there is separation of the
Sexes because if you just had open
season and sex didn't matter biological
physiology didn't matter then I know
what would happen hardly many women
would compete in the Olympics ever again
who were born with female biological
bodies it's just a fact
and it is a fact and that's why we can't
understand why the UCI has made this
huge reach to make it look like it is
okay I mean there is there is some
science that hasn't been tested out I
mean the whole idea of Sciences you make
a prediction and then you do a test to
see if it proves and they have not
proven it that you know 23 24 14 years
of being a male and the testosterone
that helps that that you know stronger
bodies bigger lungs larger heart
um and then you reduce the testosterone
that that makes you a female
um it's a delicate issue and the whole
point is whether it's athletes or
sponsors or teams and this is why I fear
for the sport
it's such an unknown right now and if
the powers that be are not going to take
control to try to fix this then we have
a problem well you're going to end up
with someone like Leah Thomas swimming
winning Olympic gold medal or a world
championship you're going to have
someone like Austin Phillips doing the
same in cycling that's where this will
go and you're going to have more and
more biological males identifying as
transgender athletes because I'm afraid
as we saw with doping for example you
know once it once it was clear that you
could win and make a lot of money and
have a lot of celebrity attention if you
cheated a lot of people cheated and I
think you're going to see the same
Martina River warned about this you're
going to see people eventually gaming
the system we see it in prisons at the
moment over here with with you know male
rapists who identifies women to get into
female prisons I'm not equating for two
things but the principles the same you
separate the Sexes for a reason be it in
sports or be it prisons albeit in safe
spaces for women or any of these things
and I think the moment you start to
conflate them then it can only end badly
that's my just honest belief about this
and I agree with you I think a lot of
the sport does as well and I guess you
know from Austin's side she seems very
nice she obviously has goals in her life
and I don't know that that means that I
I get your point
um
you know I I would look at Austin and
say well she's playing by the rules and
I'm not defending the rules
um she came and she competed and we
followed the rules and but I also think
about the biological female that was
second yeah
ultimately Michael that's the point is a
biological female has been robbed of the
chance of winning that tournament and
this is going to keep happening more and
more and more as it is doing we saw Leah
Thomas win One race against political
females in the pool by 38 seconds I
think he was completely ridiculous I've
got to leave it there Michael thank you
for speaking out because I think it
needs people in your position to do this
it's a courageous thing to do the bile
that comes your way is disgraceful and
entirely predictable but this has got to
be talked through and there's got to be
a fair resolution and women's rights
have to be protected so I appreciate you
joining me thank you very much
thank you sir